Huawei says the Mate X is the fastest foldable
5G phone in the world.
It appears to be a well-thought-out design,
too.
The display folds back to become a 6.6 inch
display, bigger that then screen on the foldable
phone Samsung unveiled last week
But the Huawei device won't be out till at
least June.
Those who can wait will need deep pockets,
and not just to fit the phone.
It will cost 2300 euros in Europe.
And in Barcelona, it's look, don't touch.
The 5.4-millimeter-thin phone is only on display
behind much thicker Plexiglas.
I still think the Mate X is quite amazing.
Amazing me because the shape and the design
of the whole foldables.
I think it is very useful.
I think it is too expensive for this device.
It is not ready.
It has a lot of failures.
I can see right now – the little stuff there.
I think for the endproduct when they release
the product it is going to be ready.
Royole - another Chinese manufacturer, thinks
of itself as the trendsetter here.
It already sells foldable smartphones - in
Europe they cost just under 1400 euros.
With our flexible screen you can make the
screen foldable.
So that you can have both the porabilties
and also the large screen viewer experience.
So it totally changes the way of the traditional
design of smartphones.
Give it more design rooms, innovation of the
smartphone.
But it's Huawei that's the star of the show
today.
The company is is going big on 5G - the future
mobile communications standard that will see
all sorts of home devices connected to super-fast
internet.
For now Huawei is concentrating on flashy
displays.
And while the company's president has rejected
US warnings that the Chinese government could
use its technology to gather intelligence
- here at the show, it prefers to
dance around
the issue.